speaking by oh by the way we have to
talk about this this is going to sound
speaking of two justice systems
this is going to sound like a story we
already did i know you're going to say
david
i know you did that story it is not an
old story it happened again
radical repugnant
trumpist congressman madison cawthorne
has been caught with a gun at an airport
again now i know you remember the story
or you might
it's because it's happened multiple
times
in august of 2021
we did the story madison cawthorne tried
to board a plane with a gun because he
did it was in his carry-on he said i
didn't know it was in my carry-on that's
what we call negligent gun ownership you
don't know where the gun is that's not
very responsible he had another run-in
with the law involving weapons in
september 20 uh september 21st of 2021
madison cawthorne brought a big knife to
a school board meeting those aren't
allowed in schools
but he is not going to be charged for
that either
and now we have yet another story
congressman madison cawthorne cited for
a loaded gun loaded loaded in his bag at
an airport checkpoint
this was this week folks
madison cawthorne was cited tuesday for
having a gun at a security checkpoint at
charlotte airport this is the second
time he's violated rules
that prohibit traveling with firearms
and carry on backs
kawthorne was cited for possession of a
dangerous weapon on city property and
then released
authorities took passet possession of
the loaded gun which is standard
procedure
according to the tsa this happened
around 9 00 am a tsa officer spotted the
gun in a bag
the police say kawthorne stated the
firearm was his and he was cooperative
a report from charlotte police on
twitter says on tuesday yesterday april
26th police officers assigned to the
airport were notified by the tsa that a
firearm was located in a bag
at a security screening checkpoint
responding officers identified the owner
of the bag as david madison cothorn
stated the firearm was his and he was
cooperative with officers
a police report indicates officers
recovered a staccato c2 firearm magazine
and nine millimeter
nine millimeter rounds of ammunition the
gun was loaded loaded loaded loaded
so
is there going to be any serious or
repercussion for madison cawthorne you
claim to be for law and order just
follow the law now how many times are
you allowed to be caught with firearms
at airport security before you get put
on a no-fly list and by the way
loaded it's against the law
to bring on a carry-on a gun even if it
is unloaded this was a loaded firearm
this is the epitome of irresponsible gun
ownership gun owners should know where
their guns are at all times
if you're unaware of where your firearm
is
that is negligent gun ownership and
number two
you should not be carrying the firearms
around loaded in this way
i understand if you are someone who
concealed carries or open carries your
firearm is going to be loaded that's
sort of like the point uh here we're
talking about a very different situation
where you are um going you're traveling
you're going through airport security
my friends who have firearms and again i
always i never talk about some a lot of
times people ask about my personal gun
ownership and stuff like i just don't
talk about that i don't see any reason
to talk about that but my friends who
have firearms
have theirs locked unless in transit or
in use
and if you're careless with a firearm if
you don't know where it is if it's
loaded when it's supposed to be unloaded
it's not responsible gun ownership by
its very definition and and we've talked
about this before in the context of
there was an accidental shooting well
what you mean is there was a negligent
discharge of a firearm
you didn't mean to fire it
and you fired it that's irresponsible
with the very rare exception of the
spontaneously firing weapon i know we
once interviewed a lawyer
about uh i believe it was a remington
rifle defect where it would sometimes
quite literally spontaneously fire
that's you know 0.001 percent of these
situations if the gun fires and you
fired it accidentally that is a
negligent discharge and it's often just
said it was just it was not an accident
it was oh okay an accident we were
talking about a negligent discharge and
irresponsible gun ownership and madison
cawthorne's behavior with firearms is
extraordinarily irresponsible what
should happen to him
i don't know
airports and airport police have long
had significant discretion when this
happens you can go on youtube and find
many examples of people who bring a
firearm or attempt to bring it through
security
and it's not uncommon that well they're
cooperative and the gun is kept at the
airport until they come back or whatever
with madison cawthorne it's now become a
habitual thing and we're talking about
loaded rather than unloaded guns i don't
know what should happen but it doesn't
really seem like it's being taken
seriously by the justice system let me
know your thoughts we'll take a quick
break and be right back
if you're looking for a therapist or
seeking treatment for mental health or
substance abuse check out compassionate
care compassionate care is a medical
practice offering
mental health treatment that's
affordable
and remote in the comfort of your home
compassionate care offers remote talk
therapy to patients nationwide you can
establish a meaningful long-term
relationship without having to drive to
an office for every appointment
psychiatry services are available
remotely to patients in pennsylvania and
new york compassionate care offers
medication assisted treatment for opioid
or alcohol addiction with the
medications buprenorphine and naltrexone
available in pennsylvania new york and
delaware compassionate care does not
require insurance they're a small
independent practice they support the
david pakman show and you can support
them and they're ready to talk to you
get a free consultation by calling
855-208-2408
or go to caredrs.com
the link is down below